Hey guys, it's really rainy out there today, who's getting wet? Who's getting droopy and droopy in their drawers? Who's getting real chilly under the collar? And who's getting ready to be heated up because of all that mess? Let's get hot on Smartless! Oh boy, guys, it is cold here in Los Angeles, you know what I could have used last night? What's that Jason? An extra blanket, maybe even a Sherpa blanket, huh?
You know where you get one, Jay? Where? Where? Well, if you go to, I don't know if my coordinates are correct here, but if you go to www.wondrishop.com slash Smartless, what's that? That's our Merch Madness store. Can I get sweats there? Do they sell Sherpa blankets in there?
Can I get t-shirts? Can I get t-shirts? Yeah, of course! What about warm socks? Yeah, of course! That'd be great for the cold weather now. Do you like joggers? Do you like phone cases?
What do you look like the joggers? Do you like popsockets? I don't even know what those are. I'm going to buy three t-shirts and a Sherpa blanket right now at www.wondrishop.com slash Smartless. You did it again. You only did two Ws. www.
It's going to be three Ws. So hard for me. And this is the World Wide Web. This is it. Yes. www.wondrishop.com slash Smartless go. We got all this new Smartless merchandise. It's so good.
The hats are amazing. Listen, for storytellers like us who are creating content, no, but just hear me out. As a content-creating storyteller, we got it, we got it, we got it. You can come and load up, speaking of loads. Wait really quick. I just want to talk about this because it's been in the news for several weeks and I'm obsessed with the UFOs that they're shooting down. And today I was watching the news and it's funny how they're kind of skirting around
it like, like it has to be alien stuff, right? It can't be. No. Sean probably not. No, but it can't, it can't just be whether Scotty can stop painting his face. It's not, there's not going to be a big, a big painting in his face. Take the tin foil out of the windows. Yeah.
No, I think it's just, it's a different kind of balloon. They're flying a different kind of surveillance device now. I think so. They said it's not surveillance or anything. No. And somebody pointed out that if aliens sent these craft over here from wherever the hell, they wouldn't be easily downed by our dumb weapons, you never know, you never know, right? They may be dumb too.
They might be dumb too. But anyway, you know who isn't Tom? Our guest today has quite the stellar and sparkly reputation. Oh, I thought this was Willie's guess. This is yours. This is mine. Yeah. Sean's get there.
It is right there. This is so fun. Really? Yeah. I can't believe we get to talk to this fella. I might get a little starstruck not just because he's celebrated here in the United States, guys, but he's very much celebrated internationally too. Really?
By the way, he's not even American. Many fans may not realize he was once cast as a James Dean type and a rebel without a cause type adaptation, which I'm obsessed with. I'm the first thing I'm going to talk to him about. And we're on the street is there's no one nicer in Hollywood. His first name in Hawaiian means cool breeze over the mountains. Guys, it's the legendary Count of Reeves. No.
He's over the mountains. Really? Wait. I didn't know that. This just picked my mood up a lot. Where are you? Are you in a hotel room right now? I am.
I'm at the Four Seasons in West Hollywood. We're not paying for that. We're not paying for that. No. No, I'm doing some John Wick chapter four press for a film. I can't wait to talk about it. You put this into your junket schedule. That is a very nice thing to do because that's a hall doing that stuff.
Yes. Come on. You're tired and you've been doing lots of press and then you got to talk to us idiots. No. This is so cool. We're going to up our game. We're going to up our game because you've got a couple of roundtables after this or you got.
No, I'm good, man. I'm good. I'm good. Dude, great to meet you, man. Yeah. Cheers. I've been such a huge fan for so long. It's so nice to meet you.
Yeah. This is so cool for us. So Keanu, let me ask you something because we as a Canadian, we always claim you as a Canadian. Is it? What's your Canadian status? Really? Where would you put it?
But wait. Let me just jump in with that. Beirut. Born and Beirut. Born and Beirut. Canada. Yeah. Chinese, Hawaiian, European.
Do you want him to answer it? I mean, you can tell me. I mean, I can just look up his Wikipedia. He's trying to show off that he did research. Yeah. The story of my past is obviously the story of my mother. And so she ran away from home when she was like 15. And she ended up going to Beirut, Lebanon, and as you do, she was born in England.
And she met a guy, and they had a kid, and that's me. And then it's a long story, but my, it does, there's a bit of adventure in their journey. And then my father had a stepfather who was Canadian, and then there's a bunch of stuff that happened, but long story short, me and my sister and my mom ended up moving into a house in Canada. And so that's how I became Canadian when I was like seven or seven years old. Did you, so did you go to, you went to school, a lot of school in Canada in Toronto? Well, I went to, I was raised in Toronto, and I went to, I went to Jesse Ketchum.
Did you really? Yeah. Do you know it? Yeah. Crazy Will. Of course. Oh, look how excited. Now he's out.
I graduated from Leeside High School. Leeside. Yeah. Yeah. I am, the two high schools that were, our grade school fed, what the fuck were they called? Northern. And.
Northern? Yeah. North Toronto. I went to NT, I went to North Toronto for one year. You did? Yeah. I went to North Toronto for one year. And I'm trying to remember the other Jarvis.
And Jarvis, so my sisters went to Jarvis and my nephew is graduating from North Toronto this year. Well, congratulations. Thank you. And congratulations to you. Is that right? Hey. Yeah.
So are you a Maple Leafs fan as well? I was. I was. I played a lot of ice hockey as a kid, and so yeah, I played a lot of hockey. I played a lot of hockey. No more. You don't, you don't, you don't play in one of these Hollywood leagues or teams. No, I never got into the Hollywood leagues.
I played a lot. When I, when I got here, I played, I mean, I played in some leagues in Los Angeles and I discovered that you could play pickup hockey basically every day. Yeah. Really? And so I played a lot of that and I'm, I'm a goalie. So is Will. Oh my God, Will.
Take it easy. So was I. I played Goal at North Toronto at the, at the rink there at North Toronto, right? Nice rink. Yeah. Great rink. Good ice. By the way, you should be noted, I got an email today from somebody I know here in
LA saying, Hey, do you want to go and play, pick up the, they call it pickup hockey. Of course we call it chinny, but do you want to go and play some pickup hockey in this league? And I said, man, I just wrote back like two hours ago. I was like, I'm too old, man. I care. No, but what, what, what if, what if they're old too and then everyone takes it easy in the corners?
Everyone's old. Yeah. But you know, and then you end up, you can, you fall or you take a bad hit and then you're like, what the hell am I doing? What am I doing out here? What am I doing? Yeah. I went to, I went to four different high schools in Toronto.
So I went to North Toronto for two years and then I went to a performing arts high school. Got kicked out of that. Sure. Really? Then I went to, I went to Dilla Sal on Avenue road, dude, dude, that Dilla Sal is on Farnham and I grew up on Farnham. I grew up, I grew up a hundred yards from Dilla Sal. What?
You guys probably walked by each other a million times. You're both the same age. I'll be you. I'll be you. I'm 52. I'm 58. So okay. Yeah.
So you were probably, you were probably walking along the street there when I was like a punk kid, you know, that's amazing. Yeah. Yeah. That's why. And then, and then there's a Hawaii in there. No. I'm sorry.
Yeah. It's my father's Hawaiian. So he, he, he grew up in Hawaii and then he got into some trouble. And so he ended up going to be living on too. And that's where he and my mom met. Where did your mom go before Beirut? Where was she? She was born in England and she went to Paris.
Wow. She was interested in fashion and design. And so I think she worked at a fashion house, I tell you. So you guys just moved around constantly? Yeah. Yeah. Even in Toronto, there's a lot of, I got a lot of gypsy in my story. Yeah.
You got a lot of good stuff cursing through you. Yeah. Is your, now is your, is your sister in the arts? She's in the equestrian arts. Okay. Yeah. She was in the arts. Yeah.
So she was into horses, training horses, riding, could do anything, everything on a horse. And that was her deal. And my, so my husband, Scotty, he is an army brat. He's moved, he moved 17 times before he was like, you know, 20 or something like that. Wow. And, but moving around made him want to desire to be stable in one place and never move again. Are you like that? Or did that upbringing make you feel like, are you drawn to like different experiences
all the time? Hmm. I think both. Oh, okay. If you can be both. I mean, I think, you can. I mean, I love traveling. I love new experiences.
I mean, I think, you know, with the arts that we're in, you know, if it works out, you get a chance to travel around and, you know, meet folks and, and so I love that experience, but it's also important. I mean, I love, I love a good couch, a little home. Yeah. Who doesn't? Yeah. Good God.
And, and then, of course, then the itch starts. Yeah. Exactly. And then it's a fever and then you're distracted and then. How long, how long are you good on the couch without, without any work or without any, any work that you know is coming up? Cause that's right. You just want to measure it.
You just want to measure it. Yeah. It's like, if you know works coming up, like you have a start date on something, I can sit on my couch for six months. But if I don't know anything's coming, I, I'm about two weeks. Oh yeah. Unemployed. I call it the working on working.
Yeah. I mean, it really depends on what the, what the journey you had before you're unemployed. Right. Right. You know, like if you, you know, if you have like, if you, if you've been working and it's been really intense for five or six months, you know, you come out of that, you know, you might not be thinking about being unemployed and working on working for a day or two, but two months.
Yeah. And if you don't do, you, you do jobs that they, they shoot a lot of nights. There's a lot of action. Yeah. There's weapons. Yeah. But I mean like, you don't have like easy days on your movies, no rom-coms for you. No, I like a good rom-com.
I got to work with Ali Wong. I did a couple of days on an Ali Wong show. She's funny. I've done, she's amazing. And, but no, I've, I've had the fortune to do some pretty, some pretty epic shooting. Like, I mean, working on Matrix two and three was 22 months. Wow. My God.
And all the John Wick's are like, that, that ain't no phone in. Yeah. No, there's no phones. I remember, I remember seeing that first John Wick. Well, first of all, I mean, for now that we're, you've opened, you, you open up. Yeah. I had a bunch of before that. So, well, okay.
Well, I'm, everybody's got a bunch. Jesus. Why are you arguing with me? I want to talk to him. He's tired. He's not going to deal with that one. And, and so I remember what being in New York, 1998 when Matrix came out, I want to say, and I know cause I have a weird thing with this and was, I couldn't have been more blown away.
I had no preconceived notion because we weren't inundated at that time, all the time with the phones and stuff of leading up to stuff. So you could kind of go into a movie clean and just for what it was. Fuck man. That was such a game changer for me, that movie. Did you know why you were filming it with the effects and all of the stuff that it was a game changer? Um, I mean, you never know while you're making something, but yeah, I knew with the Wachowskis,
the directors, I knew their vision was extraordinary. I knew the script was extraordinary and the cast and then once it got all put together. I mean, I think of that film as a perfect film. Yeah. It's amazing. And it is like, for me too, watching that film because I hadn't seen him with the visual effects and all of that, just like, yeah. Yeah, that's great.
I remember, Keanu, my oldest son is 14 and I remember just within the last couple of years, the moment of like, when I was like, we're going to watch The Matrix, man. And he's like, we're just going to, we're going to watch that because I wanted him to have the experience that I had. But you know, you, but you've always been a re in the greatest sense of the word and I don't have a better word than this, but a real director snob, like in the way that like you, you don't work in Keanu Reeves vehicles, you work in director vehicles. It seems like to me like you really appreciate someone who's got a real plan, a real vision
and you kind of work to service that as opposed to, yeah, I want to be the star and let's just find out any director that'll do. Is that, is that? Yeah, I mean, I, that's kind of you to say. I have, obviously, as you guys know, I mean, you want a director with a vision and I've had the chance to work with some directors who have been able to realize their vision in such extraordinary ways. And so to be on those sets, to be working with those artists is the best, man.
You know, it seems to me that you have the choices that you have seemed to make all the way through a very long career. You have done so much different stuff. You know, certain people, you can see them, they get sort of into a theme thematically throughout their career. You can see this sort of through line. You've done stuff. You have just zigged and zagged and consistently done different stuff and maybe that's, I don't
know, maybe now I'm going to draw the line back to like your upbringing sort of moving around a lot. Like you like new experience, new stuff. You've done period stuff. You've done the action stuff. I'm thinking of speed with Sandy and or, you know, and, and, and then they can't pigeonhole you. It's an adventure.
My own private Idaho. Dude, dude, it's fucking. Now it's first of all, Bill and Ted's. Yeah. Excellent adventure. I mean, that was, that was a game changer. Those quotable movies. I mean, I was a teenager.
I was 18 or something. When I came out, we were fucking dying. We watched it a million times. But yeah. So you start and you do all these different things and you, it seems like you have like a thirst for that. It kind of goes into like taking jobs for the right reasons. Right.
Like, is that something that are you constantly being like, yeah, I want to do something that I haven't thought of or that's scary or that's, yeah, for sure. I mean, growing up is, you know, I always wanted to do as many different things as I could. You know, that's the hope. Right. And I find that, you know, oftentimes lead roles have certain expectations on them and whether in any genre, you know, and there's also times we're working in independent or being, you know, in supporting roles, you get to kind of do some interesting kind of nooks
and grannies and have different voices, different tones and tell stories in different ways. So that, if you have the fortune, you know, if you have the opportunity to do a studio film or an independent film or something like that, then it's the cinema, you know, getting a chance to play and again, just tell different stories and different roles and try and do that. By the way, I don't know if anybody ever brings this up, but Dracula is one of my favorite all the time. I think Dracula, I mean, I don't know, I got kicked in the teeth and maybe deservedly
so for my English accent, but they may, anyway. No, one of my favorites. But I think, but my English accent aside, I think that's a wonderful film. Incredible. I think Francis Ford Coppola made a work of art that was maybe a little ahead of its time. Yeah, it was amazing. I mean, the performance, Gary Oldman.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Amazing. Amazing. Do you remind your team constantly to sort of find really interesting things as opposed to super lucrative things or star vehicles or things like that, or can you take responsibility for that? Because it just seems like everything you do is always interesting and it's never down the middle.
Well, that's very kind of you to say. It's true, man. It's true. I bet you get a lot of offers to do things that would be a lot easier, a lot more predictable, a lot safer, a lot more lucrative, perhaps. And so has it been the same team forever and they just kind of know what makes you tick? Yeah, that's the representation story has been pretty consistent with the people I've worked with over the years, but that's changed over the years as well.
Yeah. And at least for me personally, it's always been kind of what I was talking about, like how can we have a variety? What's the filmmaker? Where's it being made? And again, what's the script? What's the story? Yeah.
What's the role? Right. We'll be right back. We'll be right back. We'll be right back. We'll be right back. All right, now listen, visit topgolf.com slash smartlist to book a bay and come play around. Again, that's topgolf.com slash smartlist.
Our big thanks to Zip Recruiter for their support. Now, listen, I have not yet had to use Zip Recruiter because the only business I've got is this smartlist business. And we're so darn well staffed over here, but let me tell you something. Anybody steps out of line over here. I know how to get to Zip Recruiter. Are you guys listening? Not you, the listener, the people that make this show tick.
I just want to make sure they know that I've got easy access to Zip Recruiter and I can go out there. I can start a brand new hiring line right now because Zip Recruiter just makes it that easy. So mind it. All right, now I'm back to you, listener. Whether you're starting a new business or growing one, if you want it to be successful, you need the most talented people on your team.
That's where Zip Recruiter comes in right now. You can try it for free at ZipRecruiter.com slash smartlist. Zip Recruiter's most powerful matching technology finds highly qualified candidates for a wide range of roles. Got your eye on one or two people who'd be perfect for your job? Zip Recruiter lets you send them personal invite so that they're more likely to apply. Zip Recruiter also offers attention grabbing labels that speak to job flexibility, like remote, training provided, urgent and more to really help your job stand out.
Let Zip Recruiter fill all your roles with the right candidates. Four out of five employees who post on Zip Recruiter get a quality candidate within the first day. See for yourself. Go to this exclusive web address to try Zip Recruiter for free. This here comes. ZipRecruiter.com slash smartlist. Again, that's ZipRecruiter.com slash S-M-A-R-T-L-E-S.
Zip Recruiter, the smartest way to hire. And I'm just kidding. I'm not looking to hire anybody. We're all one big happy family. But if I did have to, it would be real easy. Guys, we're just goofing. We are brought to you in part by Game Time. Now, I was a little stressed out trying to buy tickets a couple months back.
And, you know, without mentioning the other folks in this space, it just, it was something, it was complicated. And I got stressed. I was afraid I was going to buy on the wrong night. And the prices, it's just, anyway, Game Time seems to make it real easy. It takes a stress out of it. So listen, buying tickets to your favorite events shouldn't be stressful. Game Time is the fast and easy way to buy tickets for all the sports, music, comedy,
and the theater near you. With killer deals on last minute tickets and their best price guarantee, you can stop stressing over the tickets and start getting hyped for the fun you'll have. This sounds perfect for me. Now, I've got, Sean and I happen to be real, real fond of classical music. We don't make fun of us. We just, we like it. We don't know anyone else that does.
So we go with one another. So I'm going to surprise him with some classical music tickets coming up over here at the Hollywood Bowl. So Game Time is going to make it all happen for me. And I'm going to report back to you how incredible that experience was. I'm very, very excited. All right. Now, listen, Game Time is the place for last minute ticket deals. Forget planning months in advance.
Game Time has deals on tickets right up to the day of the event. Get exclusive flash deals on tickets for football, basketball, baseball, concerts, comedy, theater, and more. The Game Time guarantee means you'll always get the best price. If you find tickets in the same section and row for less, Game Time is going to credit you 110% of the difference. That's called a guarantee gang. Snag the tickets without the stress with Game Time. Download the Game Time app, create an account, and use code SMARTLESS for $20 off your first purchase.
Terms apply. Again, create an account and redeem code SMARTLESS for $20 off. Download Game Time today. Last minute tickets. Lowest price. Guaranteed. And now, back to the show. First of all, where'd you get the bug to do it?
Why are we artists? The Unlicked Cubs. Yeah, exactly. Because when you're in Toronto, like, when people like you that just transcend, you know, whatever, we just said it a million times how incredible your career is. Do you, is it something that finds you or you find it and why? I kind of grew up in a show biz background. My mother was a costume designer.
I had a stepfather who was, you know, at the time was, you know, I just finished directing some plays on Broadway when I was a little bean. And then growing up, yeah, my mother says that I came to her when I was 15 and asked if it was okay if I'm an actor. At 15. At 15. And she said, yes, of course, son, whatever you want to do. And then, and then I started.
So I was pretty self-motivated and, you know, enrolled in a theater arts program, which will, you know, you might even know, the, was up in North Toronto. Leah Pozlin's theater group. I don't know if you ever came across that, but it was a wonderful person. They're named Rose Dubin. But anyway, so I was super self-motivated. You know, I auditioned for the performing arts high school. And I was at the library.
I was reading. I was just, you know, taking acting classes with a hug and respect for acting. I'm 17, you know, doing the Stanislavski voice work. And I, you know, I ended up getting an agent at the, at the, at Leah Pozlin's because I was playing Mercutio and Romeo and Juliet. And so I guess that was my first big break. Oh, that's cool. And you're like, this, this tastes pretty great.
Yeah, I got an agent. I started doing some commercials, sold some corn flakes and some cola. And you drove all, and you drove all the way out here by yourself from Toronto. And you're still not an American citizen, which I think is kind of cool. I get it. It's cool and not cool. I got in my first car when I was 20 and I drove to Hollywood. And of course, when I got here, they wanted to change my name.
Really? Yeah, they were like Keanu, it's too ethnic. Oh, Lord. I mean, literally like the day I, I mean, I remember I had driven across the country and remember they told me and I was like stomping up and down along the beach in Santa Monica going, what the fuck? Yeah, yeah. You know, and then I was like, okay, well, what's my name going to be?
And I was like, Templeton. Or like, anyway. Did they pitch you any names or did they ask you to go think up some? Yeah, so eventually I came up with my first and middle initial. So I was Casey Reeves. No way. No way. For a couple of...
That would work? Yeah, Casey Reeves. That would be good. Oh my God, please. He'd be a great Casey. No, man, but then I had like auditions and they'd be like Casey and I wouldn't even look up. And eventually I went back to my agents and I was like, I can't change my name.
Like one of the first plays, one first play I ever did was, was playing John Proctor and one of the lines is just like, you know, because it is my name, because I can have no other and I was the crucible. That's the signal. I was the crucible. And I just thought that was just running through my head, you know. And so, so with Ted, was Bill and Ted's the one thing that really like, how did that come to you?
And that, cause that kind of put you on the map for us to know who you are. Right? Yeah, I think for me, probably, you know, the biggest, another big break that we all need is, I was in a film called River's Edge. Oh my God. Right, right, right, right, right. Of course. With Crispin Glover.
With the amazing, beautiful Crispin Glover. Yeah, yeah, yeah. To that movie. What I do for my fucking friends. And to watch that artist work, you know, talk about being and seeing an artist kind of deal with what the expectation of a role could be or how you could even act, how you could even be in a scene. You know, for me, it was a revelation.
So he was doing it completely differently than what you thought it was going to be just reading the script. Yeah. I think everybody's standing there in the room. Right. I mean, it was just, but, but he had the essence of what the role was. Yeah. And he had his unique voice on it, which I think we all do, right?
Yeah. We all have our own voice, but the way that he was performing and understanding the form of acting too, the way that he understood the camera, the way he understood choreography and where he would go with his voice, the choices that he would make, was something to me that was revelatory. I do love that part of what we do. You know, like the audience doesn't read the script before they see the movie. So they have no proof.
They don't know what they don't know. So they get what they get and they don't get upset unless somebody sucks. And, you know, like usually people don't suck, you know, for people that are taking these big swings and you just kind of, but I bet if these, if the audience would think for one second, like if you read all these lines on a page, would you imagine this kind of performance and nine times out of 10, the answer would be no. That's what everybody on the set is dealing with. So the, the, the instinct is to criticize it and say, Oh no, that you can't play the
character like that. You know, a director will come up and say, Hey, easy with that. And let's go over here and take the character this direction. You know, and, but the audience is never going to do that. So if an actor just needs to push back just a little bit and say, well, hang on, I'm still going to get us there, but it might be a little wiggly through here. Like just let me do that. Let me play it like this.
And, and with that, you get, you know, so many artists, but you know, you get like Christopher Walken. Yeah, exactly. Yeah, you can't write that. You just, that's performance and you, you can't give it a false negative because it sounds and looks different than what you imagined. Do you remember, do you remember Crispin Glover and Wild at Heart? And he's, he's in that he's placed the, he's got all those flashback scenes and he's the
guy who's got, he's like, he's got, he's got, he's got cockroaches in his underwear and they, and he's cutting bread, cutting bread. I just, I love Wild at Heart. It's one of my favorite movies. And you just hear, I forget his character was like, what are you doing? And then he's cutting, then he goes, I'm making my lunch. And he's just in this like underwear stuffed with, and you're like, what a wild choice. And you just know that David Lynch gave him a ton of room.
Like piano, like, you know, not that there's, there isn't art and, and challenges in Bill and Ted's excellent adventure and, and, and the sequel and this and speed and all of these things. They are, you know, what people call, you know, popcorn movies, but they're just as difficult of roles and movies to make where you, did you have any kind of trepidation from going to being so trained to going into these kinds of things and worrying about the perception of them? Um, at the time, no, man, I was trying to work.
Yeah, yeah. For sure. For sure. And I, you know, and I love like for the script of, of Bill and Ted's excellent adventure. The audition process for that film is almost legendary. I mean, I think everybody read for that. And it was. Oh, really?
But I got to meet Alex Winter. Yeah. At that time and, uh, we just had one of those things where you like, you're both in the waiting room to go audition and you're like, Hey, Hey. And then we started talking and he's like, Yeah, I ride bike because I'm a helmet. I go like, I ride. And he's like, Yeah, well, and then he's like, I went to in my, in my U film school and he started talking about movies and like, and then we were working on the, we started audition
and, you know, with those, with those roles, he and I both kind of both independently came to the idea of Comedia Del Arte and the physicality of these kind of classical Comedia characters. And so like there was Bill and there was Ted. And so how would you, what was the physicalness? How did they play off of each other and a kind of punch and Judy kind of way? But like, um, and so we had a, we had an instant kind of vernacular and a way to approach these roles that, that was really exciting and hilarious. Yeah.
It was just so much fun to play. And that was something that you guys, I first of all written by the, by the great Ed Solomon too, right? I mean, great, great writer. Chris Matheson. Yeah. Just so, and was that once you guys kind of keyed into that? You know, like you said, there were so many people auditioning for it.
Was it just like you hit it? And George Carlin. And then you have George Carlin. Oh, George Carlin. I forgot that Carlin was in that too. What was that like, man? Man, he was so nice. He's super low key.
He and Alex would go talk politics and do all of those things. Yeah. One of my, I mean, he was so lovely. I remember he, uh, he's one of the few people I've asked for an autograph and he, and I said, can I have an autograph? And he was like, sure. And he wrote, uh, Keoni, fuck you. And then I was like, oh my God, George has said that to me.
I was like, cool. And I took it so personally and then I found out down, down the years that he would actually write that to other people. Yeah. It wasn't special, but it's special that you did that, man. Is there somebody that you got over your years other than George or are these people that you were just completely blown away, starstruck by? Gosh, so many.
So many. So many. I mean, I, I asked for an autograph from Lou Reed for a friend. He was like, shoot. And then he kind of scribbled it. I think I carved it in your hand. Some pathetic piece of paper. Yeah.
Sure. Yeah. Dude, what do you, what do you think about? It seems like, man, again, I just love, you've just had such an interesting, like really, really, um, unique trajectory in, in longevity. And then it seems like the last couple of years, people, I feel like every five years, people re-appreciate you like a new group of people are like, oh my God, Keanu Reeves. And the last couple of years, it's true.
And people go like, and then you've just become this thing in the last couple of years, like everybody has recognized, and it's obviously because of a lifetime of being a good guy. People are starting to really recognize that about you. And you've been, you've kind of crossed over, and I don't mean to embarrass you into this kind of weird look, man, whether you like it or not, and you can, you can avert your eyes so you don't have to look at me when I say this. You've been a sex symbol for a long time. None of us have been, have that, have that weight.
Welcome to the club. Yeah. And then you've kind of gone, and so you're like an actor and a sex symbol. And then you've kind of, you've now gone into this kind of like iconic status, like with, with culturally, no, I mean, by the way, you're 58. I know. I'm not coming on to you. You look great for 58.
He is actually a great match for you though, Will. I mean, think about his, his, his passions. We would be great if either of us were gay, we'd be perfect for each other. No. But, but I, but it's, it's, it must be kind of a bit of a trip because you're like, I'm still me, and you haven't done anything different. You get up every morning and have your coffee the same way, and then all of a sudden you're right.
Has it been kind of trippy in a way? Yeah, I mean, I think all of us have kind of had the experience of the before and the now with communication. And so I think, you know, certainly now in a now, you know, to your point, Will, I mean, I think right now I'm, I'm, is, you know, nice is nice and can be super nice and I'm really grateful for it. I do know that that is fickle. Yeah.
Yeah. But, but, but, you know, I think, you know, memes and stuff like that, you know, I remember the first time someone showed me sad Keanu. And I was like, what is this? Yeah, yeah. You know, I was used to paparazzi photos, but I wasn't used to a paparazzi, you know, I could see how like, you know, I was used to tabloid communication, right? Right.
And so this became, that was the before and now the now is something else. And, you know, and for me, I was like, I was just eating a sandwich. And I was like editing, you know, I was like, kind of like down and like, and then, and I came up with, you know, in order to kind of preserve self preservation was like, you can see a picture that can tell a thousand words. But that's always not going to be all the story to tell. All right. I mean, that kind of lensing or focusing and then the way it gets shared or transmitted.
Anyway, long story short, that was pretty fucking funny. And weird. It was funny and weird. It's fucking weird. It's fucking weird. And like, here you are on a candle and you're carrying a lamp. You know, do you ever think about the kids today who are coming up who were, you know, thinking about like when you were coming up and you were doing Bill and Ted's and all
these great movies and you shot out of a cannon. Can you imagine having to have the scrutiny that there is now? Yeah, no. I mean, it's a scrutiny and responsibilities, right? Right. I mean, I think. And you're a kid, so you don't know anybody. You're kind of dumb.
We're all dumb when we were kids. Yeah. Yeah, I unfortunately kept that going. But, um, yeah, the, the, um, yeah, I mean, I do. I, you know, I've heard of just a lot of artists having the pressure to be on social media in order to get a job. Right. Right.
Like to even get in the room. How many followers do they have? Yeah, the following kind of aspect to the kind of capitalistic idea of it. But, um, yeah, I mean, I bet it's tough. I bet it's tough, but also I'm sure it's pleasurable for some people too. Right. You know, and there's artistry to it and involvement and creativity, but, um, I think, I think the, the now is definitely more intense pressure on your private life than the before.
Yeah. I mean, the before had a lot of pressure too, but I think the, the now is even more. Yeah, for sure. Well, I mean, when you said you were 58, it's like your, Keanu Reeves is going to be 60 in two years. You've had, you've gotten a lot of shit done. Yeah. I mean.
You've been busy, motherfucker. Yeah. I know, but I haven't hit the 100. I want to be, I want, I haven't hit the 100. I want to be a hundred too. No, no, but a hundred years old, but also a hundred films. A hundred films. Oh, how many you got?
Yeah. I, I don't know. I think I'm in the 70s. Yeah. Well, you've got time. You got plenty of time. Just don't get stuck directing a bunch of them. And, you know, you'll lose a bunch of time.
Yeah. Wait, speaking of though. Okay. So I want to get into John Wick because I have a bunch of questions. Okay. So first of all, let me just start. We do have a connection because I'm kind of stating the obvious here. We have the same personal trainer. Yeah.
So Patrick Murphy is fantastic. The best. The best. I love him. He's the greatest. And he's trained you quite a bit as I understand. And he's nothing but incredible kind words to say about you. And like me, he's always blown away.
Like a lot of people are blown away by the fact that you, you do all your own stunts. I don't do stunts. But you had to in the first John Wick. You're falling on your back. He doesn't call them stunts. Oh, sorry. You do. First of all, you guys have the same trainer.
I mean, is he so exhausted after working with Keanu that by the time he gets to you, he just, because there's a real fucking there. I mean, this is okay. This is let's stand up and make a bagel. Sean, stand up and make a bagel. Here we go. There. Yeah.
So anyway, but okay. So you do your own action. Is that right? No, it's a big difference, right? Because if I'm there, if John Wick gets hit by a car, I'm not doing that. That's a stun. If John Wick is in a fight scene, I can do the fighting. And if I can do a judo throw, or if I'm going to fall on the ground,
but let me say something, jump off a bill. I'm sorry. No, no, but let me just say something. Because you fall because I've seen them. And so I'm looking at them and it's your face falling on the ground. Yeah. Well, that's falling action. But no, but that's the lens, right?
So maybe I'll do the double action. I'll do the, all right. All right. I mean, listen, I get to ride some horses. I get to drive some cars. I get to like, you know, run and jump and do a lot of, you know, interactive fight sequences. But Patrick praises you like no end because he just says,
you have such a high threshold for pain. You're like the second, if you hurt yourself, you're back in the game right away. Like I heard or I read somewhere that you, like the first day or the first week you're shooting, John Wick 2, that you injured yourself and you just got up and just kept going. Like it's like a football player. Yeah.
Yeah, there is, but I mean, but that's the kind of the joy of it too. Isn't it? Like it's not easy. I don't know about that. Once you get past 45, it's not super enjoyable. I mean, I know, but if you can do it, right? If you can try, if you can try, if you can climb, if you can climb the mountain.
But doing it, it's got to be a lot harder now. Who cares, man? Hard, smart, whatever. Shoot, come on, man. I fucking love this guy. It's rainy, it's hot, it's whatever. It's like, you're not comfortable, whatever. Get out of here.
Tell him, Keanu, Keanu, tell Bateman, you fucking let's go, Bateman, what the fuck dude? Fuck it. All right, listen, but wait, then I heard this too, from Patrick told me this, that people stop you on the street and give you feedback or ideas about the John Wick series. You should do this.
You should do that. Is that true? Yeah, once in a while. And there's some good ideas and stuff, but... Really? Yeah, I mean, the world, I mean, I think that's what's really... I'd be like, I think I got it. But I really appreciate it.
I really appreciate with John Wick how the world has opened up with the idea of a high table. There's so much mystery in films, but in a weird way, somehow it all makes sense and you authentically feel that everyone has a past. Yes, I love that. Because the first one is like, you fucking kill my dog, I fucking kill you.
And you're off to the races, right? And that's what the thing is. And then it's just kind of grew and grew and grew. I'm kidding, it's deeper than that. But it grew and grew from there. But not really. But not really. But it's so cool.
It's really, really cool. Revenge and freedom. Is there anything you heard over the years and that feedback from your fans? Like, what is the main people... What is the main thing people say? I think people try to connect why all is happening. And they try to connect, like, maybe my wife is really...
Is she really dead? Is she part of the high table? Is the character Winston? Is he really pulling all of the strings? What's the Bowery King? Is it a fever dream? Is John Wick... So we have people trying to kind of connect dots
and try and kind of get a big overview of the story and get to it. It's really cool. Yeah, it's kind of fun. And we will be right back. Our next partner is Athletic Greens. I take AG1 by Athletic Greens literally every day. I gave AG1 a try, I don't know, two years ago, maybe? I wanted better gut health.
I wanted more energy. I wanted a simple way to take vitamins and minerals that were important to my body. I didn't want to have to take all these supplements. I wanted one place. And AG1 is that place. I put it in the thing. I shake the thing.
I down the thing. And it's so good for my body and it tastes great. This is the best option. This is the best option for easy, optimal nutrition out there. You take one scoop of AG1 and you're absorbing 75 high-quality vitamins, minerals, whole foods, source, superfoods, probiotics, and adaptogens to help you start your day right. This blend of ingredients supports your gut health,
your nervous system, your immune system, your energy, recovery, focus, and aging. You know what I love most about it? You can mix it with water when you're traveling. You can put it in a smoothie like with all the other stuff that you make your smoothies with. And it tastes great. It tastes great any way you want to roll.
I mean, it's the healthiest way to start your day for me, and I know it will be for you too. Right now, it's time to reclaim your health and arm your body with convenient daily nutrition. It's just one scoop of AG1 and a cup of water every day. You don't need a million different pills and supplements to look out for your health. Athletic Greens is going to give you a free one-year supply
of immune-supporting vitamin D and five free travel packs with your first purchase. Go to athleticgreens.com slash smartlist to give AG1 a try. That's athleticgreens.com slash smartlist. Check it out. All right, back to the show. When you do a film like the John Wick films, do you... What is your...
Because they are so physical. What's your... When you rap, what is your sort of recovery? Are you like, I need four weeks on a beach or four weeks at home with the door shut or I need to like go to parrot? Like what do you do to like recover from those really grueling movies?
After when I get home after I finish filming them. Yeah, yeah. Yeah, it starts with collapse. Yeah. But it's an interesting thing. I don't know if you guys have found this, but like, I don't know, coming off the road or coming off the series or the work that you're doing.
You can be really tired, but then there's also a restlessness. Yeah. I don't know if you've experienced that. Like, you know, I'm just going to stay home. Well, I'm just going to get up and go get something from the fridge. Right. You know, but there can also be the periods where like, don't talk to me.
No, I don't want to work. But then you're like, but there is a restlessness. And then once I get through the restlessness from it, then it's like I go into a world that I don't quite understand in the sense of like, how do I rest or who am I? What is the meaning of life? What am I doing? You're trying to reconnect with people, you know,
because making films of that kind of time scale, you're in a time machine. You know, you know, everyone around you, then you go away and you go down the river on your kind of independent journey. They're going down a river and then you have to meet up at the other side of that distance to travel. So so much of their lives have gone on. Yes, you can have contact, but you're not involved, you know,
and so it's kind of in a weird way, syncing up to those around you and syncing back up to your life. You know, at the same time that you're totally exhausted, restless, questioning everything. And then of course you have the fear and desperation of being unemployed. Yeah. And then you want to, you know, then you're back into it. Is it as much of a draw for you as it was when you were just
trying to make something of your career and something of yourself and carve something out? Because it seems like you're very respectful of life itself, like the real stuff as opposed to, you know, career stuff and making fake life. And having done so much, do you start, and I'm just, I'm sort of projecting myself, right? I mean, I'm 54 and you start thinking about what we're closer to death
than we are to birth. Oh, sorry, no way. 54. Well, I'm just, you know, like at what point do you, do you, like, what's the right ratio, you know? Do you think about, well, there are certainly, I'd like to play a role like this and a role like that or direct them this or don't do a player, whatever it is.
Like, do you have certain things you still want to check off? Yeah. Before you take a bigger vital life? Before I die? Yeah. Before you kick it? Before I kick it. Yeah, I mean, to answer your question, I mean,
I guess part of it is I still love acting and I still love the creativity of it. Yeah. And I still have ambition and hope. And I still want to do good work and work with people. And so I still want to do that. And I love the, I love the goal of a hundred. That's a hundred.
Yeah. And I want to be a hundred. That would be fun. Yeah. And any big thing pulling you in life, like, do you have certain places you'd like to travel to? Do you have a sport? Well, I'm hoping to do a play on Broadway.
Yeah. I mean, I haven't done that. Whoa. That sounds good. She's like, Sean, Sean's got his, and it's Tabasco theater. It's going to be hot. Tabasco.
Yeah. Yeah, they sponsored. It's not the Bolasco. Oh, nice. How do you know that? How do you know that? That's good. That's Tabasco.
Hey, guys, check me out. Everything's hot. It's a hot night. It's Tabasco. It's a hot theater. You come in cool, you leave hot. Listen, I feel like this would be a generic question for anyone else other than you,
but what's your favorite action movie? Oh, shit. One of your favorite action movies. One of them, yeah. Oh, my gosh. Oh, my God. And was there one... Do you think I'd have that, like,
ready on my sleeve, right? Yeah. Like, oh, well, here's the list of the favorite action movies. Come on. I don't think I do. I don't have one. Okay, well, what do we mean by an action movie?
Like, you know, there's action movies. I mean, because it could be like a, it could be Bruce Lee and Enter the Dragon, or it could be Raiders of the Star. It could be Raiders of the, it could be Rollerball. Oh, is that an action movie? Rollerball.
Sure, it is. A science fiction. Yeah, no, no, no. That was good. No, but you almost said Raiders of the Star. Could it be Chitty Chitty Bang Bang? Yeah. I mean, I don't know.
Yeah, that card gets hairy. I mean, I don't know. Sean Defund. But I just to answer your question, I mean, I grew up, I mean, like, what is it? Like The Towering Inferno? I mean, what about all of the chariot movies, right?
What about The Westerns? Gumball Rally. What action movies are we talking about? Oh, I mean, I guess Formative. I mean... I don't mean just people, like, moving in a scene. I just meant, like, people fighting.
I know. I know. Fighting and blowing stuff. I'm kidding. I'm kidding. Good for you, Keanu. Yeah, Sean. Define it.
I mean... Listen, Keanu, John Wick 4, right? 4. There's 4. There's 4. It was released in March, and it's how great is... I can't wait to see it.
That's kind. Yeah, I can't wait. I'm a big, big fan of you and those movies and all your movies. We've taken up a lot of your time. Thank you for being here. I love you. You're the man.
You're absolutely the man. You're very cool. Thank you, fellas. Thank you very much. Nice to meet y'all. I'm jealous that Sean had you as his guest. You've been on my wish list for, like, two and a half years,
so I'm so happy you're here. I can support that. Yeah. Yeah. Stop ducking me out there. You know, I'd like to spend more than just 57 minutes with you. Yeah.
Come have dinner with us one night, all right? Yeah, that'd be so fun. Cool. Thank you. Do you live in Los Angeles, Keanu? I do. I'll just text me then.
Text me the address. All right. Cool. All right. We love you. Thank you for being here, pal. Thanks for doing this. Thanks, man.
Thank you, buddy. Appreciate it. Thank you so much. See you, pal. Bye. Hey, guys. It's Keanu Reeves. That was Keanu Reeves.
Did you recognize him? I did recognize him. He has not changed. He's not changed a bit. 58 years old. He looks exactly the same. He's 32. He looks 32.
Jason, you look like his older brother. You son of a bitch. You know what I mean? What? He's just skated over the fact that I know he didn't. Well, I call him stunts, but action sequences, whatever. He has too much respect for the people who do stunts. He's so unassuming.
He's so unassuming. And it's all real. But I'm not dissing them. I'm just saying, you know, take after take after take. Movie after movie after movie. Your body, it's just, I don't understand. Can you say, maybe, can you guys relate to this? When you were younger, did you have like, I didn't have an older brother.
So, but I had, I had guys who were like my dad. My dad, my, my godfather's son, Ward Brown was my idol. And he was a couple of years, he was like three years older than me. And everything he did, I wanted to do. He played hot. Everything. Cause I like looked up to him. I was like, Keanu, I could seize one of those guys that I've always been.
He's like a few years older and like, I just want to do it. What's he doing? He's totally right. And he's got that. He, he lives in that same space for me. I feel the same way about Pitt. I'm like, and everything. Hey, man, how's it going?
What are you doing? Like, yeah, we're just away. I'll do that. It's like a cool factor. I'll never, I'll never achieve. Yeah. Yeah. Well, you started out nice with it.
You shared the same body instructor. What's his name? Body. Body instructor. What's it called? Shred. Shred. Guys, my brain's broken today.
A trainer, like a personal trainer. Like a body trainer, right? Body instructor. Body instructor. Listen. But he also seems, he's so humble and unassuming. So humble. And I love him.
It's real. And it's all so real. He doesn't need any attention. He's almost shy. Yet he's in a public, public role. Yeah. I find that admirable and interesting. I didn't even get to the thing that I said in his,
in his intro, which was he, I wanted to ask him, the whole point of my intro was to ask him about, he starred in Paula Abdul's music video, Rush Rush in the nineties. And I was like, why is Keanu Reeves in this video? It was so wild. I remember it was like a big deal because I was obsessed with that video. Maybe he was dating her at the time.
That's what I wanted to ask. Well, he's not, he's way, no, no, no, he's way too discreet. He never would have said it. Call him back, Sean. Okay. This is the first time we ever want to get, we want to get a guest back. We didn't get to a lot of stuff because there's so much to talk to,
talk to him about. I know. I want to talk to him more about the matrix stuff, but anyway. I mean, you did a terrible job asking questions. If I'm being honest. Yeah. You're going to lose your nomination next year. You are.
Oh, you've already, you've already a lot. You're never getting back to host of the year. Well, I can probably see that award go. Bye. Bye. You're just using a bye for bye, huh? That's right. Okay.
Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. smart. Smart, this is 100% organic in our tisently handcrafted by Rob. Armjolf, Bennett, Barbeque, and Michael Gran Terri.
Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart.
Hi, so listener, before we go, we wanted to introduce the audience to someone very special today. Please meet someone special. SmartList Media is doing our very first podcast called Bad Dates with the amazing, incredible Jamila Jamil. Hi. Welcome. Jamila Jamil.
Do I clap myself? Yes. Clap yourself. Enthusiastic. Thank you. You can give yourself the clap. Yeah, yeah. If you're thinking of giving yourself the clap, this is called Bad Dates, right?
Right. Unbelievable segue. Yeah. The show is called Bad Dates, yeah. Yeah, and are you, well, tell the listener basically what it's about beyond what the title says. It is relatively self-explanatory. It's just me and some of my favorite comedians and people coming on to disclose the sordid
details of the silliest and weirdest and grossest dates they've ever had. And the reason I love this subject is because it's very bonding. It never fails to ignite a conversation wherever you are. It brings like barriers down, but also there's just a democracy to it because it just doesn't matter how hot you are, how smart, how rich, how famous, no one is exempt from a shitty fucking date. Right. But I would guess that you have never had a bad date because you seem to know how to
communicate in any way possible to make it all work, like you can answer the questions or you can ask the questions, like some people just don't only know how to do one. It comes to a standstill when I am, I'm not going to say aroused, but when I'm interested, all of my skills fly out the window and really like I have no way of receiving a sort of social cue. So really you have to be inside of me for me to understand that you're interested. Oh, given the current climate, that's not appropriate. But you're saying if you like the other person, you start to lock up a little bit.
I complete. I lock up and I shut down. Yeah. Will's got that with Charlize Theron. He can't. You don't need to, you don't need to go wide with that. She knows. Don't worry.
She's aware. It's fine. Well, we all have that with Charlize. There are. Have you had a favorite guest yet on bad dates at all? I mean, anybody in come to mind, who could you be hinting at? I don't know. Sean, you've been a wonderful guest on the show.
Well, give us, give us, give us a taste, Sean. What was your first date? I don't want to ruin it, but it starts out with me meeting a guy in a bar with workout pants in a bar. And we're both super drunk. We go back to his place and he, before we get to the goods part of the story, he asks, can I, do you mind if I microwave a burrito really quick because we go at it? That's where it got.
Not a euphemism. Not a euphemism. I would have loved it if you said, you cool if I shower real quick before we keep talking? Yeah, it was, it was a real dream, Sean was on with Conan O'Brien. We've had Tig Notaro. We've had Nikki Glaser. Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. Conan's been on a date?
I know. Just the one. That's the most, yeah. And it was a disaster, thankfully. So he came on the show to talk about it, but it is just like, it is quite astonishing how much I've learned about a lot of very famous people and also just how many people have shit their pants on a date. I don't know if that's anything that any of you have, have literally shit their pants.
No way. It's actually like, it is, it is the great equalizer. The asshole is the great equalizer of humanity. And I think it's been overlooked politically, but we've uncovered it on the show. Fascinating. I want to hear all about that. I am tuning in. Oh, by the way, you just got Jason's attention.
The dates and the hooking up, fine, no, it's fine. But once you get into the- Short wrap. The anus. Yeah. The anus. The wheels of the story. The wheelhouse.
Sean, am I right? Yeah. Could you call the show shit show? I basically should. But I mean, there are varieties on what we're learning on the show, but it is just, I just want people out there to know that you are, you are not alone if you think you are. Like the stories are so wild and so funny and so absurd. And we're not shitting on single life because God knows married life is fucking its own nightmare.
But we're just trying to like have an intimate, funny conversation about something that I think is deeply relatable. My story amazingly didn't involve any shit, but I've had my own like extraordinary disaster. Sean, I've told you the story before, but I can share it with you if you want an idea. Please do. Yeah. Of how much disaster is out there. I am, I tried to have my first ever one night stand because I've, I've only kissed
six people, right? Come on. In my life. But it is sadly true. I started very late and then I, I was slow on the uptake. And so I, I thought, you know what, in my thirties, I'm going to have my her era that I've always dreamed of. It's going to happen.
And I, I, I, I got the sense that I was about to have my first ever booty call, a man that I'd been sort of casually going on a few dates with just hanging out with, we hadn't done anything yet. He texted me and said, do you want, like, shall I come over and I was like, oh, 11pm. I'm definitely going to get my first, so you can even hear what's happening to my voice just talking about it. I suddenly become like a bit more like Mary Poppins about the whole thing. But I was like, oh my God, I'm going to get a casual shag.
It's so exciting. So he, he turns up at my house, 11pm on the door, walks into my apartment. I've only been living in America for a week at this point, right? So I don't know anyone or anything. And he takes three steps in and collapses face first on the ground. And all of his front teeth, we're talking at least 12 here. Out of his mouth, across my entire living room. So now there is blood and teeth all over my room and he's having a seizure.
So I've never seen someone have a seizure in real life before and I panic. I think he's going to die. I call 911, which is also slightly exciting because, you know, I'm English and they call that in the movies. So I feel very Hollywood right now, I call 911. They send in the fucking police to turn up the fire brigade, the paramedics. Everyone comes rolling into my house. I now have about 25 men in my apartment, which is not how I'd expected my house to be.
And you're just in lingerie, right? You were ready to go. No, not quite, but close. And this man is covered in blood. He's, he's, he's split his chin all the way open and they're trying to resuscitate him. They managed to bring him to, and they're like, excuse me, sir. Like, you know, have you, have you taken anything? Do you have epilepsy?
And he was like, oh, I might have had some cocaine, but he was like, but I always have cocaine. And I was like, oh, it's a small red flag. It's not a huge one. It's a little, it was just, I think the word always at his age felt slightly disturbing. Wasn't going to be a short date. No, exactly. And then they were like, have you taken anything else?
And he was going, no. And he's hiding in the street like this because he's got no teeth now. And so they start putting the blanket over him to take him out. And as they go past his cock, he gets a raging erection, which feels inappropriate in a moment. And they're like, sir, have you taken anything else? And he turns around and he looks directly at me and makes full eye contact and just goes, I might have had some Viagra, which is, I might have had some Viagra who don't speak toothless.
So that's a combination you don't want. So then you hook up. So quickly sucked him off and sent him on his way. Yeah. He got carried out in on a stretcher in the middle of us Hollywood of quite famous actor. So we had to put a blanket over his cock, but also one over his face. And he's just, there's just like pitching a tent through West Hollywood as he gets taken to the hospital.
So that was, that was my first and last attempt at a boutique hall and have been in a long term relationship since a week from that day. Oh my God. I can't wait to get you drunk one day and find out who that guy was. I can't believe Thoreau has never told us this story. Right. He's literally open about his mistakes. Normally you'd think that he would.
So that is what can happen. I know. See, I live for those kinds of stories and you can see how everybody has one or two or five or 10 of these horrible stories. Ask her if she's ever forgotten a line on stage, you know, any weird theater stories. Hey, give me a really horrible theater story. That's just a dynamic. You have to tune into smart list for that one.
But for all bad date stories, tune in. Yes. Bad dates. When do we get to start airing these things? So March 28th, it'll be on Wondery Plus and Amazon Music. And then March 27th, it'll be on all services. And you can just sit back, relax, and enjoy the truly horrible tales of some people's dating experiences.
It's just amazing what we'll go through to get a shag, isn't it? Yeah. That's true. Boy, that's a quote. Well, we're lucky, Jamila, that we have you taking us through this. Yeah. It's going to be so great. We're really excited for it.
You're our first one. You're our virgin podcast. Yeah, you're our first one. Thank you. No pressure at all. No pressure. Yeah. Yeah.
Thanks. I'm a massive fan of all of you. I don't know if I can, because this podcast is so weird and gross that I think it's going to fly. Well, thank you, our big fans. Thank you for doing this, and we can't wait to listen. Likewise. Thank you.
Thank you, Han. Bye, Jamila. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Smart. Last.
Smart. Last. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.